[Musique]
aurait pu s'entendre et rendre hommage
n'était pas un devoir c'était une
évidence pour nous tous quand il a fait
pour notre territoire à Vienne mais
aussi pour la France
[Musique]
et puis la phase finale ici sur le
parvis du Futuroscope et de l'Arena la
Plaza qui est en plein chantier
aujourd'hui quelque chose effectivement
d'exceptionnel on n'imaginait pas rater
ça dans la Vienne une fois tous les 100
ans il faut qu'on en profite maintenant
[Musique]
la Vienne demeure le premier partenaire
des communes c'est dans notre ADN
nous sommes liés par ce pacte de
confiance par cette passion de l'intérêt
général par cette volonté partagée de
servir nos concitoyens
et je suis convaincu que notre avenir se
construit avec les mères et les élus
locaux qui font vivre leur commune leurs
habitants
c'est ça la République des territoires
en laquelle je crois
[Musique]